but more and we're sick of all those new
hunters I've had some old ones speaking
of old ones Peter Brown a guy was gonna
go by age if we done it by age Eric Tay
Peter Brown Mike you're like 12 13 13
I'm Jared and a half my gate here last
week Oh gave him the beers you're not on
air you're gonna tell the internet have
it before it's okay in Harlan's you can
drink from age 4 is gonna be a while
propelling through the windows don't
swat us because of beer while the
[ __ ] hey how you guys doing it's been
a late night tokyo game show you guys
were up you two were anyway app
recording footage from like midnight
o'clock air tay you were telling me
earlier that you were like sleepy sleepy
sleepy comment all together and then
somebody said blood-borne your address
you impressed what do you think about
the new trailer I mean I'm excited cuz i
didnt going into the year did I think I
was gonna love blood-borne or play
blood-borne to the extent that I did
know so like to see it I it was on my
radar liquor in the summer and your name
just kind of fell off for whatever
reason and just seeing it's like oh [ __ ]
that's right that's still a thing and
then a lot of the stuff that you kind of
want which is like more weapons and
stuff like that is pretty much what they
showed and you can't be mad at that
trailer eat that one sword where you
like jacket into that spinning song oh
yeah it was like dead rising 3 or
something listen yeah there's some go an
hour Lakshman arrow yeah as well there
was a shield at one other really yeah
like I feel useful yeah do me off cuz he
actually blocked like the dragon's
breath or something so I'm like whoa
whoa whoa I thought the shield was not a
thing there's a fire bullets I have no
idea I thought Jonathan like a long
rifle I may be it music news I kasami's
doing Dark Souls 3 and he's doing this
as well and he's gotten the like
documents swapped by accident and that
is gonna be gone in Dark Souls 3 so
thing we're like some guy trips in the
hallway and it's just a mess of paper
and this will work better me to get
together I so I gotta call the questions
rises trailer first of all I can ask my
hearty about this is this set in yarn
them do you think it is it looks like it
yeah
sure I mean they show these aerial views
which that's definitely that looks
exactly like central yarn them toward
the beginning of the game but I mean
then they have these new like the these
entirely new areas it looks like but
it's called the old hunters which leads
me to believe maybe it's a prequel Tay
and I were saying maybe has to do
gehrman he's one of the final bosses of
the game he's the one that's kind of
guiding you throughout the game then he
turns out you have to you know spoiler
alert he's put in the game he should
yeah he saw he killed me a lot of times
what a day but yeah it looks a lot like
your honor but still that Victorian kind
of horror London looking place if they
have said that this is a this is a brand
new set of hunters and so we won't be
taking your your old character in or
anything so yeah it's likely that this
is sort of an isolated expansion pack
that you can play as opposed to like
some endgame content and also there's a
bunch of buses here to kind of look like
they're modified from from the first
game as well yeah yeah dart bees parlous
it as you have fire now that well
there's dark well the [ __ ] par
looking kind of thing god this game
looks so good I know that's awesome
forgot a greater looked ah you guys
surprised about how much you enjoy
blood-borne like I know you're a massive
fan of it uh yeah I've been a Dark Souls
fan for a few years now I'm played one
and two both twice a few times played
demon's souls never finished it but
blood-borne it's probably still if not
my frontrunner it's one of my
frontrunner for game of the year so far
I've got to finish you know not to get
into a game of year conversation yeah I
have yet to finish metal gear and we
have a lot more coming and there are a
lot of other great games but blood-borne
was that singular experience I had this
year where I'm like that was [ __ ]
awesome i nee I played it twice I want
to start a third new game plus it's just
so much of what i love about like action
games like that it's just it tests your
test you it's a great challenge and
everything but it's also just so well
designed in terms of combat and
everything i love the world of it you
know there's like all that underlying
lore which i didn't really care about
but the more i played it was like i
might as well kind of start paying
attention to this stuff and the setting
itself is awesome i know like other
games this year have done the victorian
lended like the order 1886 yes and the
kit come very similar to blood-borne
yeah it everywhere on scores that's like
a baby or something yeah that game was a
real piece we won't that's a game we
won't be talking about game earlier I
wouldn't imagine Peter I was a big fan
of blood-borne I'd never played the doc
Searls game before I'd like attempted to
on PC like was really into it play
blood-borne absolutely adored it and
like you said the combat was incredible
what did you think about of here I think
the game is fascinating like the way
that it paints the world you know it
encompass any small details just in the
presentation alone right then there is
all that narrative in the back end then
you also have this amazing gameplay
that's in the middle but this game
pisses me off because i suck at it and i
really want to see everything that it
has to offer and i just i wish i had all
the time in the world or at least more
skill anyway till I really get into it
all it it really does fascinate me to
know when and I think it's like it's
such a great accomplishment and you know
I played demon's souls back when that
first came out and I really enjoyed that
I skipped over dark souls pretty much so
blood-borne is still that game that I
like really want to get back into you
because I don't want this wave of great
Miyazaki games to pass me by I don't
want to be just watching from the
sidelines that's my problem to fix it I
feel the same way because when I saw the
trailer for this I was like [ __ ] I know
never completed blood-borne yeah and now
it's like sitting there with the witcher
3 and i'm still going through metal gear
solid like I've this guilt I went about
I went to the beach on the weekend is
like any metal gear solid and I came
into work and people were like oh yeah
what how many hours you and I'm like 20
and they're like what's wrong whatever
you playing it I haven't completed the
witchy I never [ __ ] expensive bikes
coming later this year it's games like
blood-borne and metal gear that
embarrassed most of the games that come
out in our industry like I hey it's just
funny to me sometimes when you look at
stuff and you're like why are people
actually like betting the farm on
something like this yeah when they're
going up against games like blood born
in Metal Gear like more power to you for
making the effort and really trying and
following your dream but sometimes I
feel like those people should really
just ban together track make something
that's really good what you know that's
the thing about like the like Miyazaki
games that you know the joke is that
they'll ruin all their games for you and
that hasn't done that but it is the most
rewarding experience for me this year so
far i mean the witcher was long and
everything and i finished it and I felt
like I really accomplished something but
blood-borne it's one of those games and
not to be not to be like contrarian but
it's it is very hard but once you really
get it down in your patient like on the
new game plus i played through and it
was it wasn't easy by any means but I
was just so in
the rhythm of that combat and like that
dodging in that counter-attack and you
know trying to refill my health bar that
by the second time i played through
maybe today you could speak to this i
really felt like i had mastered
something yeah the challenge rewards
sort of loop on that is coming yeah it's
it's like it's going to be the weirdest
reference ever it's like third person
action braid like oh man this is [ __ ]
hard getting anything for granted yeah I
fantastic everything and then the
satisfaction when you when you completed
is like is amazing at a you play a lot
of video games yeah I know you've played
with you know what are we like 12 hours
of you playing destiny already today and
blood-borne this expansion packs coming
at November 27th there's going to be a
sort of special edition version coming
at December fifth pack them in the with
the full game will you have time for
this November 24th is like to wheat less
than it's exactly two weeks after for f4
comes out do you think you're gonna have
time to play the expansion pack I hope
so like so here's so blood-borne was my
first Miyazaki game never played dark
souls never played demon's souls loved
it I wanted to do fallout never played a
fallout game I'll admit it I suppose you
can shoot me now um so oh wow I know so
I want to get into that but like now
that blood-borne is like right around
the corner like I will probably just
gravitate there real quick hopefully
it's real quick I don't know because
like you said you're starting over but
if the bosses are kind of the same hmm
then you might still be able to get
through it pretty quickly minus like the
new stuff we encounter that we haven't
seen like some of those bosses we
haven't seen them before but unless they
do something like pretty like pretty
substantial in terms of like cleric
beast or something like that they're
probably going to move somewhat similar
so you're going to be able to kind of
deal with them and maybe the novelties
in the weaponry though maybe that's the
a specially they want you to sort of
replay familiar ish bosses but you're
like you're attacking me differently I
mean that games once once you kind of
like dig deep and like you played
several hours like Mike said you just
kind of start seeing the patterns and
you're just like oh man I can't wait
just do it and then boom and just stick
the arm through the first time i got
like I couldn't get the gun to work for
the longest time I was like oh kept
hitting it too early to late all the
time and then that first time it didn't
call
it was like a [ __ ] door on the leg it
was like checking keys on a lock and
then it goes and it just was like the
most satisfying thing the world and then
you get it like every single time after
that as well okay I'm pretty I'm pretty
hoppin mad one yeah and that's coming
out like i said november 24th at this
holiday season is gonna be amazing i'm
like just gonna sit at home eat turkey
and play a bunch of great video games
I'm quitting a year for good just to
play all the games yeah been a good year
man its twenty fifties been a great year
you said it was gonna be like devoid I
said that I said I said yep I'm so sorry
I didn't episode of the point about me
saying how much this year's like a snore
fest nope you've got a great game of the
year at discussion it's a little piece
together this year Peter it's gonna be
rough that's why Kevin left he was like
you saw was gonna happen so I'm going on
vacation in a couple weeks so I can come
in with a clear mind take the witcher
complete the winter plays of that
expansion swimming as well yes there
also is that expansion roswell great
alright set segment before we realize
you up anymore at time and let us know
what you think bloodborne the old
hunters course coming out late November
let us know if you've completed blob or
NYADA you looking for the expansion
please put your thoughts in the comment
box below
you